يعتبر هذا المطار في نيبال
أحد أخطر المطارات في العالم.
يقع مطار هيلاري المعروف أيضًا باسم لوكلا في
منطقة الهيمالايا بالقرب من جبل إيفرست، مما يجعلك
تشعر بالذهول من مكان المطار
نفسه حيث قطرات الماء شديدة الانحدار.  وعلى جانب
التل الوعر للغاية، يبلغ
طول مهبط الطائرات ذو الاتجاه الواحد حوالي 1700 قدم، مما
يجعله أقل من ربع طول
أقصر مدرج في مطار جون كينيدي.
معظم مدارج الطائرات مسطحة تمامًا
وطويلة جدًا، في حين أن هذا على جانب التل
سيكون قريبًا منك  إلى 30 40 درجة في
منحدر الجبال، حرفيًا في
الطرف الآخر من المطار،
يمكن أن يتغير الطقس بسرعة كبيرة حيث يمكن أن ينتقل من
السماء الزرقاء الجميلة والرياح الهادئة إلى 10
دقائق بعد ذلك، يمكن أن تهب، يمكن أن
تكون السحب مبللة، يمكن أن تتراكم
وفجأة لا يمكنك رؤية أي شيء
وفقًا لشبكة سلامة الطيران، فقد
مات أكثر من 50 شخصًا بسبب عمليات الإقلاع
والهبوط أو الاقتراب من لوسلا بسبب
البنية التحتية الوعرة
والطقس القاسي الذي ذهبت إليه عدة مرات حيث
هبت الرياح  كنت في طريقي للتو
إلى النهائيات هناك
وتحولت الرياح من أربع أو خمس عقد هادئة
إلى 14 عقدة مفاجئة وليست رياحًا خلفية وبدأت
الأمور تصبح قاسية ووعرة وانتهى
بي الأمر بالتأخر لمدة خمس دقائق فقط
أو الخروج من  الوادي هناك الذي
نسميه وننتظر لنرى ما إذا كان
الطقس قد هدأ وهو ما يقول إيطاليا
لم يهدأ لذلك اضطررت إلى الالتفاف والعودة إلى
المنزل. يعتبر لوقا بوابة
إيفرست لأنه أقرب مطار إلى
معسكر قاعدة جبل إيفرست.  يمكنك رؤية
كل جبال الهيمالايا هناك، جبل إيفرست،
وجميع الجبال الأخرى هناك، فأنت
جزء صغير من هذا
المشهد الطبيعي في ذلك الوقت وهو أمر
متواضع للغاية